-Finally, guys, I was
watching TV the other day.
I was just flipping
through the channels
and I came across
this show on TeenNick.
It's called "Ew!"
And it's a pretty good show.
And a lot of people say that
I look like the main character.
I don't know
if I see it, though.
But, anyways, here,
look for yourselves.
Here's the latest
episode of "Ew!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, everyone!
Welcome to "Ew!"
My name is Sara.
And if you're wondering,
that's S-A-R-A with no "H,"
because H's are ew!
Joining me today is the
new foreign exchange student
who just moved in across
the street, Bjergen Kjergen.
Hi, Bjergen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Swedish accent ] Hi!
-Hi. How's it going?
-Pretty good, yeah.
It's great to be on you.
-Yeah. I love your pigtails.
Did you braid them yourself?
-No. They were done by
my sisters,
Herdie, Kerdie, and Donna.
-Yeah. Well, they look amazing.
So, Bjergen, are you ready for
the school dance competition
next week?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I'm also a bit nervous,
you know?
I've never danced in front
of other people before.
-Ew! Don't be shy. It's easy.
We can practice
the dance together right now.
I'm going to put it on TikTok.
-♪ You turn me on
like a light switch ♪
♪ When you're movin' your body
around and around ♪
♪ Now, I don't wanna
fight this ♪
♪ You know how to
just make me want ♪
♪ You turn me...♪
-Let's see if it went viral.
It only has seven likes. Ew!
That's not a lot of likes.
-What?
-I said,
it's not a lot of likes.
-Oh! I's not a lot of likes.
-Yeah, yeah.
Anyway, let's play a game.
What's your favorite game,
Bjergen?
-Well, in my country,
we have a game, yeah.
It's called the floor
is a fluva.
-Is that like the floor is lava?
-Yeah, but we
call it a fluva.
-Can two people play
it together?
-Oh, does a pjerp wear a hjerp?
-Yes?
-Yeah. Of course. Let's do it.
-We can put this on TikTok, too!
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-Ready? Yeah.
-Ready? Alright, go.
Here we go.
-Yeah.
Bjergen, the floor is floggon.
The floor is -- I'm gonna go
for the slide tackle.
Oh, my --
-Are you okay?
-What is going on down here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys doing some parkour?
Hey, check it out.
I got some moves of my own.
365 degrees, 24/7.
-Ew! That's my stepdad, Gary.
Get out of here, Gary!
-Hey, come on. You girls
are making some TikTaks?
Have you seen that new A.I.?
♪ Hash brown like ChatBLT ♪
-Ew!
-Anyway, if you like
cinnamon buns, hun, your mother
and I are upstairs making
some gluten-free pastries.
And this just in --
I have a sensitivity.
♪ If you want a sweet treat
that's safe to eat ♪
♪ You gotta make sure
it doesn't have any wheat ♪
♪ A-take a big bite
and a munch, munch, munch ♪
♪ Pastries for breakfast,
dinner, and snack time ♪
♪ Munch, munchie ♪
♪ Munchie, munch ♪
♪ Munch, munch, munch, munch,
a-muchidy, munch ♪
♪ You spell "munch" backwards,
it still spells "munch" ♪
-Ew! Gary, get out of here!
Come on!
-I had one more.
Catch it on the flippity-flop!
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, it's time for the "Ew!"
Speed Round, okay? Ready?
-Oh. Okay.
-Here we go.
"Minecraft."
-Ew!
-Jibbitz.
-Capybaras.
-[ Laughs ] Ew!
-Fjallraven backpacks.
-Uh...ew!
My cousin makes those.
[ Laughs ]
-John Leguizamo.
-Cute!
-Wait. Really?
-Yeah! He's, like,
really talented, you know?
Have you ever seen
"To Wong Foo,
Thanks for Everything!
Julie Newmar"?
-"To Wong Foo
Thanks for Everything!
Julie Newmar"?
-Yeah.
-No, never heard of it.
-Oh. Alright.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
-Oh, look.
Bjergen, our dance is getting
a lot of likes.
We're going viral!
-Oh, that's good.
-I'm getting a FaceTime!
From "Spam Likely."
-Oh.
-I'm going to answer it.
-Yeah?
-Hello?
-Hey, Sara. Hey, Bjergen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-O-M-jeans!
It's Charlie Puth!
-Charlie Puth, I love you.
-I just wanted to say
I saw your video.
I love your moves.
So I want to offer you both
front-row tickets
to my next show.
-Front-row seats?!
What is life?! What is life?!
This is crazy!
-Yeah. It's crazy!
-That's all the time
we have for "Ew!"
I want to thank Bjergen
for joining us tonight.
Tune in next week. Ew!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My thanks to Drew Barrymore
and Charlie Puth.
You can catch him on the
Charlie Live Experience tour
this summer.